[Music]
since their emergence over 200,000 years
ago modern humans have established homes
and communities all over the planet but
they didn't do it alone whatever corner
of the globe you find Homo sapiens in
today you're likely to find another
species nearby Canis lupus familiaris
whether they're hurting hunting sledding
or slouching the sheer variety of
domestic dogs is staggering but what
makes the story of man's best friend so
surprising is that they all evolved from
a creature often seen as one of our
oldest rivals canis lupus or the gray
wolf when our Paleolithic ancestors
first settled Eurasia roughly 100,000
years ago wolves were one of their main
rivals at the top of the food chain able
to exert over 300 pounds of pressure in
one bone crushing bite and sniff out
prey more than a mile away these
formidable predators didn't have much
competition much like human
hunter-gatherers they lived and hunted
in complex social groups consisting of a
few nuclear families and used their
social skills to cooperatively take down
larger creatures using these group
tactics they operated as effective
persistence hunters relying not on
outrunning their prey but pursuing it to
the point of exhaustion but when pitted
against the similar strengths of their
invasive new neighbors
wolves found themselves at a crossroads
for most packs these burgeoning bipeds
represented a serious threat to their
territory but for some wolves especially
those without a pack human camps offered
new opportunities
wolves that showed less aggression
towards humans could come closer to
their encampments feeding on leftovers
and as these more docile scavengers
outlasted their aggressive brethren
their genetic traits were passed on
gradually breeding tamer wolves in areas
and near human populations over time
humans found a multitude of uses for
these docile wolves
they helped to track and hunt prey and
might have served as sentinels to guard
camps and warn of approaching enemies
their similar social structure made it
easy to integrate with human families
and learn to understand their commands
eventually they moved from the fringes
of our communities into our homes
becoming humanity's first domesticated
animal the earliest of these prototypes
seemed to have appeared around 33,000
years ago and would not have looked all
that different from their wild cousins
they were primarily distinguished by
their smaller size and a shorter snout
full of comparatively smaller teeth but
as human cultures and occupations became
more diverse and specialized so did our
friends short stocky dogs to herd
livestock by nipping their heels
elongated dogs to flush badgers and
foxes out of burrows thin and sleek dogs
for racing and large muscular dogs for
guard duty with the emergence of Kennel
Club's and dog shows during England's
Victorian era these dog types were
standardized into breeds with many new
ones bred purely for appearance sadly
while all dog breeds are the product of
artificial selection some are healthier
than others
many of these aesthetic characteristics
come with congenital health problems
such as difficulty breathing or being
prone to spinal injuries humanity's
longest experiment in controlled
evolution has had other side effects as
well generations of selection for
tameness have favored more juvenile and
submissive traits that were pleasing to
humans this phenomenon of selecting
traits associated with youth is known as
neoteny and can be seen in many domestic
animals thousands of years of
coevolution may even have bonded us
chemically not only can canines
understand our emotions and body
language but when dogs and humans
interact both our bodies release
oxytocin a hormone commonly associated
with feelings of love and protectiveness
it might be difficult to fathom how
every Pomeranian Chihuahua and
are descended from fierce wolves but the
diversity of breeds today is the result
of a relationship that precedes cities
agriculture and even the disappearance
of our Neanderthal cousins and it's
heartening to know that given enough
time even our most dangerous rivals can
become our fiercest friends have you
ever wondered how dogs see with their
noses or if they experience pain the
same way we do learn more about our
brilliant best buddies with these
animations
[Music]